now listen closely to house speaker
nancy pelosi because she's signaling
democrats very dark and devious turn
she's already laying the grain
groundwork for the possibility that her
party may not accept the results of the
midterms if republicans take over
congress
it is absolutely essential for our
democracy that we win i fear for our
democracy and the republicans forever to
get the gavel we can't let that happen
democracy is on the ballot in november
democracy is on the ballot in november
what a concept well nancy's twisted
thinking democracy only works if
democrats win
and if democracy didn't work well the
logical conclusion would be to
invalidate the election results right
what else would you do
now once again democrats are guilty of
what they accuse trump of
whether we're talking stacey abrams in
the 2018 georgia governor's race or
hillary in the 2016 presidential race
these people are always vindictive sore
losers
and seeing the writing on the wall
pelosi knows that her party's about to
get shellacked because they're getting
dragged down by a president who seems to
be decomposing before our eyes
a second poll in as many weeks has trump
winning in 2024 the harvard-harris poll
has him up by a significant margin of
six points
now look any poll is just a snapshot in
time i don't make too much of it and
it's very early but i think this matters
here because in 2016 trump led in just a
handful of head-to-head matchups against
clinton well we all know how that turned
out
but for 15 months now voters have been
witnessing biden in action
and lit they're now living in the
wreckage of his policies
and we know they're miserable these
polls are just showing us that americans
genuinely are regretting their votes for
joe biden
now things are so bad for the white
house that donald trump kicked off
twitter and facebook is more influential
in many ways than the liberals currently
in power
almost everything trump predicted what
happened under a biden presidency is
coming true
joe biden is weak he's too scared to
stand up to the radical left of his own
party they will make every city look
like democrat-run portland oregon
no one will be safe in biden's america
china would own our country
if joe biden got elected it's one of the
biggest scandals i've ever seen they
found the laptop the family on the
laptop
he's gone into hiding for five days he's
gonna have gas prices of six dollars and
seven dollars
now all of that happened
meanwhile voters see now that everything
biden democrats and the media told you
in 2020 was a lie
i'm going to stay in my message i've
started off saying we have to restore
the dignity and honor of the office
donald trump is
a russian operative jab at biden's age
as if there is something wrong with
being a senior citizen the public widely
thinks biden is better on covid joe
biden will be way better for the economy
oh my god i forgot about him now biden
of course isn't the adult in the room
that he promised there was no russian
collusion and biden isn't sharper than
ever at his age
middle-class americans aren't better off
hunter biden's laptop was real biden did
not defeat covid biden doesn't have a
china strategy america is not more
respected in the world
and voters are seeing that there are
worse things than mean tweets
but because democrats are incapable of
moderating their views or abandoning
radicalism they revert to their old
strategy
try to ban their opposition or prevent
trump from running again or disqualify
anyone who ever agreed with him on
anything
hence you're seeing all the
hyperventilation and the regime media
about possible trump white house
criminality around jan 6. and we're
learning now of a new gap in another
white house record white house phone
records that were given to the house
january 6 committee show a more than
seven hour gap what exactly was
ex-president
the ex-president doing on january 6.
learning of what appears to be a massive
and blatant cover-up
now democrats somehow think that
pleasing the press which is obviously
obsessed with hating trump is the same
thing as pleasing the voters
well obviously it's not it's an epic
failure
the ugly truth is the self-proclaimed
defenders of democracy hate our system
and they also hate most of the voters
they want the entire electoral college
scrap they want to pack the court they
support justices who disregard the plain
language of the constitution
and for all their tough talk against
autocrats like putin
they prefer their own brand of autocracy
where only they and their big tech
oligarchs not the voters get to decide
who's worthy
worthy of being heard and worthy of
running for office
in fact unless there are republicans
like i don't know liz cheney and mitt
romney democrats don't really think you
should exist at all
now remember their mantra
conservatives are a threat to democracy
trump's puppets are putin's puppets
they're all insurrectionists and racists
and anti-lgbtq and just mean people who
want to burn up the planet gun nuts
trying to drive their huge trucks to
complain at school board meetings
it's so stale it's so it's insipid none
of it is landing with the public
the voters are not worried about january
6 they're worried about six dollar a
gallon gas
they're not stressed so much about
climate change they're stressed about
crime
it's all unraveling at home and biden's
team thought that boost his popularity
by sending him to poland
so they're so desperate now for traction
they're even going back to the character
assassination that biden took part in 31
years ago
spurious attacks on justice clarence
thomas
now this time they're using his wife's
personal activism against him this is
both ludicrous and pathetic more on that
travesty later in the show
the left has been trying to cancel trump
since about 2015 and they're still
trying today
now if he doesn't run they'll do the
same to any republican candidate who
steps in to try to fill that void
you already see what they've tried to
unleash against florida governor ron
desantis lie about his parental rights
legislation lie about his covet record
even try to criticize him when he was
with his wife at her last chemotherapy
appointment
how low can they go
but the better question is how low can
joe go in the polls and how long will
vulnerable democrats in choppy waters
tie themselves to this sinking anvil
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else